Fernandez merci d'être là merci ça me
fait plaisir voici notre galaxie la Voie
Lactée
200 milliards d'étoiles à peu près à peu
près là donc 200 milliards de soleil
autour desquels tournent des planètes un
certain nombre de planètes entre 1 et 3
en moyenne à peu près mais ça peut aller
jusqu'à 7 8 planètes des fois comme
notre système solaire un peu plus
on se situe à peu près par là dans cette
zone au bout du bras ici bon le système
solaire est par là donc c'est ça
minuscule dans la minuscule
crée d'angoisse existentielle et la
nouvelle exoplanète elle est juste à
côté en termes de grandeur de notre
galaxie là elle est à 100 années-lumière
mais il faut savoir que notre galaxie
ici fait 100000 années-lumière c'est
grand ça prend 100000 ans à notre à la
lumière à la parcourir OK et qu'est-ce
qu'elle a la toi 700e c'est une planète
qui tourne autour donc d'une étoile là
c'est pas une photo là mais c'est
rassemble à la terre c'est une image
d'artiste elle ressemble effectivement à
la terre elle est dans dans ce qu'on ce
qu'on appelle la zone habitable c'est à
dire la zone près de son étoile ou la
l'eau peut exister sous forme liquide et
en plus elle a à peu près le même
diamètre de la Terre un petit peu un
petit peu plus petite 95% de soleil
c'est son soleil ça c'est la fameuse
planète en question et donc elle est
intéressante parce que elle possède une
atmosphère et parce qu'elle est dans
cette zone habitable donc elle a des
caractéristiques qui ressemblent à la
planète Terre ça c'est le satellite qui
l'a détecte qu'il l'a détecté
en 2018 et qui qui commence à fournir
énormément de données et notamment qui
avait trouvé déjà trois planètes autour
de cette étoile là et en refaisant une
observation récemment on s'est aperçu
qu'il y en avait une quatrième dans ce
qu'on appelle la zone habitable
optimiste on en a on a trouvé beaucoup
des exoplanètes depuis plusieurs années
là c'est puis réaliser à chaque fois bon
est-ce que cela fait combien il y en a
qui sont dans cette zone habitable dans
les 2000 qu'on a trouvé il y en a pas
tant que ça en fait on en a trouvé
beaucoup mais en fait on en a pas trouvé
tant que ça pour le moment parce qu'on
cherche dans des zones particulières
grâce au satellite test on espère en
trouver encore beaucoup plus mais on en
a quelques milliers pour le moment des
des exoplanètes qui sont dans la zone
habitable on en a beaucoup moins et puis
des exoplanètes qui ressemblent à la
terre qui sont dans la zone habitable
mais on commence à les compter sur les
doigts de la main et c'est ça c'est
cette rareté qui est vraiment
intéressante et et on a besoin de d'en
trouver pour essayer de comprendre
comment se former notre système solaire
et comment la vie est apparue sur terre
donc j'aimerais qu'on remettre notre
galaxie vous au plus profond de vous
vous croyez qu'un jour on va trouver
autour d'un de ces soleils une planète
qui à peu près que les mêmes éléments
que la terre donc est habitable que de
l'eau que oui parce que il y a 200
milliards vous l'avez dit 200 milliards
d'étoiles dans notre propre galaxie il y
a des milliards et des milliards de
galaxies dans l'Univers donc forcément
quelque part il y a une planète qui a
les mêmes caractéristiques que la terre
et dont la vie a pu se développer comme
sur terre
si on peut remettre oui le système
solaire James web là le nouveau le
joujou extraordinaire il est autour du
Soleil pas très loin il est il est pas
très loin en fait il est au point L2
entre la Terre et la Lune en fait à
trois fois de la distance entre la Terre
et la Lune on verrait même pas sur le
petit point ici c'est vraiment au centre
il est vraiment très proche il est très
proche puis il peut voir au-delà de la
galaxie il peut voir un peu partout il
peut voir au-delà de la galaxie ce qui
est intéressant avec James web c'est
qu'il va regarder cette cet exoplanète
là plus tard pour pouvoir justement
analyser correctement son atmosphère et
essayer de de comprendre exactement
c'est absolument extraordinaire là
bijoux c'est un bijou on a un instrument
canadien à bord parmi les quatre
instruments qui sont sur ce télescope là
et on a une équipe de recherche ici on
remonte la lumière donc on remonte dans
le temps on remonte dans le temps mais
comme l'étoile n'est pas très très loin
simplement sans années-lumière de nous
on monte pas si loin dans le temps juste
sans aller et on peut être capable
d'analyser correctement son atmosphère
et de trouver ce qu'on des particules de
vie en fait des signatures de la vie des
biosignatures à vendre se quitter on va
aller les Russes je change de sujets
complètement mais je reste dans l'espace
les rues sont on a appris ça aujourd'hui
vont aller sauver les cosmonautes russes
les astronautes les cosmonautes oui qui
ce qui ne pouvaient pas revenir parce
que leur Soyouz était défectueux avant
d'en envoyer un autre on va envoyer une
autre ils vont devoir rester un petit
peu plus longtemps par contre dans
l'espace parce qu'ils vont on va
l'envoyer puis on va attendre quelques
semaines voire quelques mois avant de
les rapatrier sur terre c'est un petit
peu comme si on a la ça fait déjà
quelques mois ils étaient prévus que tu
reviennes en haut au mois de février ça
aura fait 6 mois donc ils vont rester
encore quelques mois probablement trois
quatre mois avant de pouvoir redescendre
sur terre mais ici on voit très bien la
fuite là c'est vraiment impressionnant
et avec ça il devait rentrer avec ça
un problème effectivement et ça a été
causé probablement par une micro
météorite qui est rentrée en contact
avec un tuyau justement du vaisseau un
petit caillou de 1 mm mais qui va qui va
une très très grande vitesse mais une
qui a beaucoup d'énergie et qui fait que
beaucoup de dégâts c'est pour ça que les
débris sont très très dangereux dans
l'espace pour la vie humaine très bien
on va suivre cette quête de l'exoplanète
parfaite où il y aurait de la vie
monsieur Fernandez à très bientôt merci
bientôt merci beaucoup